ambiance de fin de mandat au département
d'indre-et-loire dernier budget avant
les élections de juin débat contenu donc
et budget contraint en cause l'explosion
des dépenses liées au rsa et les
incertitudes sur les recettes
malgré cela les investissements sont en
hausse +10 millions d'euros samuel colin
un dernier budget marqué évidemment par
les conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire avec en premier lieu
l'augmentation des dépenses de rsa
près de 8 millions d'euros de plus prévu
cette année au budget cela représente
66% des coûts supplémentaires estimées
duo kobe de 10,9 et pour financer ses
dépenses de fonctionnement
la marge de manoeuvre est réduite après
la réforme de la fiscalité locale cette
année le département est tributaire des
taxes sur les ventes immobilières les
recettes qui sont elles des recettes
conjoncturelles vont devoir financer des
dépenses qui elles sont structurels
évidemment du jour au lendemain une
crise immobilière
autre fait on peut passer de 100
millions d'euros de recettes
parce qu'elles sont conjoncturelles 60
millions comme c'était le cas et
quelques années et la grâce aussi malgré
tout une politique volontariste sur le
volet investissement 83 millions d'euros
15 pour cent de plus qu'en 2020 sont
inscrits au budget cette année avec
comme premier budget d'investissement
les collèges mais aussi tout ce qui
touche aux bâtiments à la transition
énergétique et écologique puisqu'on a le
premier contrat de performance
environnementale de france donc c'est
tout ce qu'il nous faut faire en
solidarité et tout ce qu'on veut faire
je dirais de manière volontariste en
relance parce qu'il faut d'abord tenir
bon un plan de relance local financé en
partie par la dette
et encore une fois par les recettes dues
aux taxes sur les ventes immobilières
101 millions en 2020